hey guys so recently I had a lot of
people wanting me to do a video on this
topic so I'm gonna go ahead and do it
so recently and Julian Michael's gave
her opinion on a ketogenic diet and I
just want to go through point by point
and talk about it so let's get started
this business for a long time what's
changed the most over the years the
reality of fitness and nutrition is
they're all just fads reskin right I
mean if you think about it like right
now it's keto and like I don't know if
anybody's as old as me in this room but
that ty it used to be called Atkins and
my mother did it in 1980 so you know so
so it is true the Atkins diet does put
you in ketosis
but the Atkins diet is pretty high in
protein so keto is moderate protein okay
so I just want to clarify that people
will take fads and trends and reskin
them with a different name
what does keto is Locarno is exactly it
puts you in ketosis but you know but
that's not good for you no it's not in
the end of the day just like two plus
two will always equal four when it comes
to health it's an energy equation eat
less use common sense with your food
choices and move more and that's just
alright guys so that is the solution we
if we just eat less and move more we
would all lose weight first of all if
you're in practice for any period of
time and you're working with people one
on one especially over the age of 40
especially if they're female especially
if they're pre menopausal you're gonna
run up against a situation with a very
slow metabolism and eating less and
moving more is not going to work so one
thing she really doesn't realize is that
exercise has a very small influence over
your ability to lose weight maybe if
you're lucky it's 15% that means that
85% of your results in weight loss has
to do with eating science
all right let's go to another one the
keto diet I don't understand like why
would anybody think this is a good idea
your cells your macromolecules are
literally made up of protein fat
carbohydrates nucleic acids okay so
let's talk about that point this is one
of the million reasons why you should
not do a ketogenic diet because your
cells are made of fat protein
carbohydrates and nucleic acids most of
your brain is fat most of your nervous
system is fat most of your endocrine
system is fat then the rest is protein
you actually don't have a large amount
of carbohydrate that makes up the
structural part of your body yes it can
be used as fuel but it doesn't make up
body cells so if your brain and nervous
system and muscles are mostly protein
and fat why wouldn't you want to consume
a higher fat moderate protein low
carbohydrate diet the diet that she
recommends is very high in carbohydrate
so what physical structural component of
your cells are high in carbohydrate
there is none when you do not eat one of
the three macronutrients those three
things I just mentioned you're starving
your cells all right so let me just kind
of explain this and this is mainly for
new people it's not for people who've
been watching my videos it's really
obvious that she just does not
understand this one really important
topic in relationship to the Q generic
diet and that is the word insulin she
does not understand what that is and
what it does how it functions in the
body so for those of you that are new
insulin is a hormone made by the
pancreas and one of its functions is to
lower blood sugars okay and it gets
triggered by carbohydrates when we
consume too much carb we raise insulin
too much and then do we develop a
condition called insulin resistance
your body's blocking it when you get
instant resistance what happens is the
body starts making more of it to try to
connect with that cell because it's it's
being resistive those macronutrients
serve a very important purpose for your
overall health and well-being each and
every one of them period end of story
you might process sugar you don't eat
processed grains and to make a very long
story short avoid the keto diet so when
you do a balanced diet and include all
this carbohydrate you're gonna keep
insulin very very high in the presence
of just a little bit of insulin all the
fat burning hormones that get blocked
and nullified so in other words insulin
blocks and prevents weight loss the more
insulin in the bloodstream the harder it
is to lose weight if someone has a slow
metabolism and they have a little too
much insulin they're gonna have even a
tougher time losing weight despite how
many hours of exercise that they do and
when you develop insulin resistance
you can't absorb those nutrients so the
concept of everything in moderation or a
balanced diet is a very bad idea so I
looked at Julian's website just to find
out what food she's recommending of
course you can do toast you can do fruit
like apples and bananas you can do
yogurt waffles pizza pop chips that's
processed potato okay these are all just
gonna raise insulin it's gonna make it
harder and harder to lose weight and one
more little point about this is that
she's part owners with a company called
SodaStream and some of the products have
sugar in it so of course she has to
justify that I mean the ketogenic diet
right now is exploding it is the fastest
trending diet right now and because she
spent years promoting the same old
low-calorie low-fat whole-grain eat
everything in moderation snacking
between meals she obviously has to
defend that viewpoint because there are
so many people searching for the
ketogenic diet and her whole thing is
the exact opposite of the ketogenic diet
so it's really obvious that she's not
trying to understand it she doesn't have
a clue she doesn't understand insulin
and she just has to invalidate it
because
basically opposing her diet all right so
let's just continue this is an article
NBC internal investigation probe whether
Biggest Loser contestants were getting
drugs so right now there's a lawsuit
going on to determine if there was drugs
involved to help people lose weight
Jillian Michaels was one of the personal
trainers involved in this show and very
very few of these contestants ever kept
the weight off simply because they found
that it slowed their metabolism let me
show you they found that the average
contestants metabolism had dramatically
slowed down and although they may have
continued to eat healthy and exercise
they had trouble keeping the weight off
so the big problem with the biggest
losers is the carbohydrate content when
you keep the carbohydrates too high it
actually slows the metabolism and even
keep ptosis by itself needs to be done
in a healthy way because it's not lose
weight and get healthy it's get healthy
to lose the weight now that might sound
really simple but it's very very
effective especially if you want to keep
the weight off so for those of you that
are new to keto don't get discouraged
when you hear things like this learn the
facts understand why it works how it
works
understand insulin I put a little mini
course down below for you personally to
get the facts and not the opinions that
are not true so you yourself can get the
amazing results that keto has the
potential to give you keto is low carb
is exactly it puts you in ketosis but
you know but that's not good for you no
it's not so I've lost 130 pounds with
keto and intermittent fasting and I love
it I feel amazing little old me was on
350 milligrams of blood-pressure meds
every time I complain to the doctors
they just keep giving me more and more
and it wasn't helping me so I decided to
quit everything and do keto in a minute
fasting and it is so working I'm the
healthier for it I feel like it they've
had it back thirty years to my life
I lost from July to November I lost 60
pounds no bad plan I've been on keto
since a year ago January I'm 76 I've
lost 25 pounds I've been following your
plan for like the last 14 months and I
have lost 40 pounds brought back my even
see below five point five which is five
point four now and kind of reverse my
diabetes and also lost my stomach inches
about eight inches
wow that's not bad I've been doing keto
since December so I lost 42 pounds I'm
in maintenance now I'm back to the
weight I was pretty much in high school
lost 40 pounds Wow I've been on your
keto diet since five months and I've
lost 50 pounds no bad plan insulin
dependent type-2 I'm 72 years old I was
on a hundred units a day of insulin and
I've been able to bring it down to 20
units so I am calling you last 62 days
you know and I lost almost 50 pounds
you're on steroids the end of November
it's been going going pretty well lost
about forty six pounds or so now no bad
plan have gotten rid of all of my
arthritis so my journey through keto and
intermittent fasting has been something
that has literally like changed my life
it has also saved my life you know I
started keto diet because of fighting
brain cancer and before that I was doing
the complete opposite and I never
thought in a million years that I was
going to be consuming low carbs and I
never thought that I would feel the way
that I do and now I feel better than I
ever have when I'm really not supposed
to you know I was going through
chemotherapy and radiation and that's
kind of when I found the ketogenic diet
and you know doctors like this is gonna
happen this is going to happen this can
have
they gave me literally a book of side
effects and symptoms and problems I was
going to have and I literally had none
of them and I keto diet intermittent
fasting has been so incredibly powerful
and overcoming that and that's it's
something that has changed my life in
more ways than one other than physical
results it's mental results it's just
emotional balance it's incredible
and again keto diet has literally saved
my life